une médaillée olympique à Villepreux le
Rachel championne du monde 2009 de Paris
pondo était présente auprès des jeunes
sur une journée défense et citoyenneté
cette rencontre unique permettait
d'associer les valeurs du sport et
celles de la citoyenneté nous avons
choisi cette thématique tout simplement
en vue des des Jeux Olympiques 2024 le
sport en fait c'est le dépassement de
soi c'est c'est voilà l'abnégation j'ai
envie de dire ça s'est réunit certaines
valeurs
la multimé le rachel a présenté son
parcours elle a notamment intégré le
Centre national des sports de la défense
au sein de l’armée de terre cette
organisme vise à présenter l'excellence
sportive du ministère des armées à
travers les compétitions internationales
l'armée c'est pas que le militaire pur
qui part en OPEX mais aussi les les
sportifs et tous les autres métiers
qu'on peut trouver au sein de l'armée
le rachel a participé aux Jeux
paralympiques 2020 de Tokyo ce palmarès
n'a pas laissé les jeunes indifférents
au début elle travaillait au McDo et que
grâce à du coup à l'armée à la pub
s'investir à 100% de ce sport c'était
très touchant même en avec la situation
d'handicap elle a pu en arriver jusque
là ce qui est à nous a sensibilisé elle
nous a dit que malgré que nous malgré
qu'elle soit non valide on peut tout
faire il y a rien qui est impossible je
suis une femme avec un handicap quand on
dit que quand je dis que je suis
championne du monde je vois dans les
yeux quand même il y a les petites
étoiles qui font rêver et cet événement
spécial thématisé autour du sport ne
restez pas moins une journée défense et
citoyenneté présentation des métiers de
l'armée et rappelle autour des droits et
de voir du citoyen à la fin de la
journée chaque jeune s'est vu remettre
son certificat de participation
nécessaire à l'inscription de certains
examens